one of the trademark texts of the
american school system is harper lee's
1960 novel to kill a mockingbird for
decades it has been widely read in high
schools and middle schools as a key
anti-racist text but how did this novel
with its southern gothic and buildings
roman elements become a book that in
2006 the british said every adult should
read before they die ahead of the bible
that's a flex
[Music]
kill a mockingbird was written by harper
lee and was loosely based on lee's real
life experiences the book tells the
story of gene louise finch better known
as scout a young girl growing up during
the great depression in the fictional
town of maycomb alabama with her older
brother jeremy aka gem and her widowed
lawyer father atticus finch a name that
will be imprinted on the world
forever
atticus is appointed to defend a black
man named tom robinson who is accused of
sexually assaulting a white woman named
mayella yule this causes a lot of racial
harassment towards the finch family and
at one point in the novel atticus has to
stop an attempted lynching with the help
of scout and some other children which
is
traumatic as hell
scout and jim watched the trial from the
black section of the courtroom it is
revealed that mayella is lying and
attempted to seduce tom but was beaten
by her father who has been sexually
abusing his daughter despite being
labeled as white trash tom is convicted
for the assault and is later killed
while trying to escape jail mayella's
father bob tries to get revenge on
atticus by attacking gem and scout but
they are saved by the town recluse boo
radley bob is killed from a knife wound
from radley but it is covered up and
scout is changed forever by this
experience as you would expect for
having witnessed three murders within
the span of a year so who was the mind
behind the mockingbird bornell harper
lee in monroeville alabama she was also
the young daughter of a lawyer father
named amasa coleman lee one of her
childhood friends and long-term writing
companion was truman capote who visited
their town during the summers they would
end up living near each other years
later in new york city
after publishing mockingbird lee went on
a bunch of book tours worked in the film
adaptation of her novel and then just
went on to lead the successful life of
someone who published one awesome book
just one
one book
no sequels
the success of to kill a mockingbird was
instant and surpassed the expectations
of lee tenfold professor alice hall
petry wrote in the introduction of on
harper lee essays and reflections during
the 80-year period between 1895 and 1975
mockingbird was the third best-selling
novel in the united states and the
seventh best-selling book of any kind
sales have not fallen off in the ensuing
25 years in 2001 for example more than
one million copies of mockingbird were
sold it has been kept alive through its
pop culture influence via the film
adaptation and being regularly included
in text for middle school children of
course just because a book is taught in
school doesn't automatically make it
popular people aren't this interested in
something like the scarlet letter and
even that wasn't a huge success when it
was released unc chapel hill professor
emerita doris betts ties its longevity
to the very simplistic morality of the
text in her essay the mockingbird's
throat a personal reflection in scout
finch lee has produced a girl as
appealing as joe marge of little women
but stopped her story sooner than luisa
may alcott stopped hers and the point
where initiation became new maturity by
producing no other novels lee also has
left readers feeling that this book has
particular significance in that it
contains all she had to say or all she
could yep
only one and with all of that symbolism
and light discussion of race it raises
the question what exactly is the value
of teaching to kill a mockingbird versus
an actual book about race written by a
black author gerald earley professor of
african american studies states i read
to kill a mockingbird the summer before
i read richard writes uncle tom's
children a famous collection of stories
by a black writer about race in the
south the difference was of course
astonishing because the perspectives
were so clearly different the right
stories taught me two contradictory but
inescapable facts first that books like
to kill a mockingbird were inadequate
for me as a black reader and failed in
their fumbling literal way to give me
black people as i knew them to be and
second that i needed books like to kill
a mockingbird if ever i were going to
understand the south as a construction
of the white southern mind to kill a
mockingbird offers some sevens of safety
for white readers who do not want to
feel alienated or called out by an
anti-racist text they can see scout and
her father atticus as a fair depiction
of southern progressivism and put the
legacy of racism and all of its terrors
on other white people but it does that
as professor isaac saney writes in the
case against to kill a mockingbird by
making atticus a white savior and
turning the black characters and their
community into pawns on scout's journey
perhaps the most egregious
characteristic of the novel is the
denial of the historical agency of black
people they are robbed of their role as
subjects of history reduced to mere
objects who are passive hapless victims
mere spectators and bystanders in the
struggle against their own oppression
and exploitation which brings us to the
complex issue of atticus finch himself
one of literature's great white heroes
what does the role he plays in the books
actually say about the role white people
play as allies
well
not much of anything according to bad
tweeter malcolm gladwell in his essay
the courthouse ring atticus finch and
the limits of southern liberalism finch
will stand up to racists he'll use his
moral authority to shame them into
silence he will leave the judge standing
on the sidewalk while he shakes hands
with negroes what he will not do is look
at the problem of racism outside of the
immediate context of mr cunningham mr
levy and the island community of maycomb
alabama atticus delivering an inspired
defense of tom robinson and protecting
him has positioned him especially in the
eyes of white audiences as the perfect
ally
until
goset a watchman
and it is at this point i am obligated
to have to discuss
gossetta watchman so remember how harper
lee only had that one awesome book
well that changed in 2015 when gossetta
watchman was released the book's road to
publication was a controversial one the
novel was rediscovered and lee released
a statement with harper collins saying
in the mid-1950s i completed a novel
called ghost of the watchmen it features
the character known as scout as an adult
woman and i thought it a pretty decent
effort
my editor who was taken by the
flashbacks to scout's childhood
persuaded me to write a novel from the
point of view of the young scout i was a
first time writer so i did as i was told
i hadn't realized it had survived
so was surprised and delighted when my
dear friend and lawyer tanya carter
discovered it
after much thought and hesitation i
shared it with a handful of people i
trust and was pleased to hear that they
considered it worthy of publication
i am humbled and amazed that this will
now be published after all these years
some argue that this rediscovery was
suspicious because there were some
conflicting reports about the state of
lee's mental health and if this was ever
meant to be published but people were
excited i mean it's the sequel to one of
the most popular best-selling books of
all time why wouldn't they publish it
and then it was bad like
really really bad alexandra petrie of
the washington post said in her review
it is the jar jar of classic literature
it takes place in a beloved fictional
universe and it's uncomfortably racist
it has at best a scholarly interest i
can't imagine that lee would want it to
represent her in the world i don't think
it should have been published michiko
kakutani for the new york times
specifically addressed in her piece the
big point that got people upset the fact
that their beloved atticus finch was
racist
atticus is a racist who once attended a
clan meeting who says things like the
negroes down here are still in their
childhood as a people or asks his
daughter
do you want negroes by the carload in
our schools and churches and theaters do
you want them in our world
in mockingbird a book once described by
oprah winfrey as our national novel
atticus praised american courts as the
great levelers dedicated to the
proposition that all men are created
equal
in watchmen said in the 1950s in the era
of the brown v board of education
decision he denounces the supreme court
says he wants his home state to be left
alone to keep house without the advice
from the naacp
and describes naacp paid lawyers as
standing around like buzzards this was a
really awkward moment to be in atticus
people were betrayed it was the last
season of game of thrones level of
distraught their khaleesi turned
fascists so quickly and without warning
some people like nabako akage a writer
and educator saw this is another reason
why to kill a mockingbird
is not that ideal of a text to teach
about anti-racism
not simply because it was a very white
voice on black oppression but also
elements of classism on which kind of
white people are to blame for the
situation in jim crow america
lee is certainly not the first
southerner to blame poor whites for
racist violence in the south it's a
practice with its own long history in
1932 the well-known liberal southern
journalist gerald white johnson wrote in
the then influential north american
review that
southerners with money in the bank do
not lynch and that lynch bobs were
usually composed of fellows who have not
two nickels to rub together those
inexpressibly forlorn outcasts known in
the south as the poor white trash there
are however moments in the novel in
which you see lee falter in her attempts
to make only poor whites responsible for
the region's race problem and absolve
fine families for the nature of things
in the south when she acknowledges that
both rich and poor whites mistreat black
people as you grow older atticus tells
gem you will see white men cheat black
men every day of your life but let me
tell you something and don't forget it
whenever a white man does that to a
black man no matter who he is how rich
he is or how fine a family he comes from
that white man is trash but in the end
lee reverts back to scapegoating bob
yule and other poor white trash for so
long mockingbird was able to give white
readers a story to teach them about
racism but also removed them from any
accountability of perpetuating that
system
they had atticus to show them that it
wasn't all of them and watchmen took
that away when i first tried to kill a
mockingbird for myself in college i
found it a very readable novel and i got
through it fairly quickly while well
written and definitely good i found
myself glad i didn't read it in school
for school because i found myself asking
the question who is this for it is not
without merit but it doesn't center
black characters or black experiences it
simply observes them through scout it is
an introduction to empathy but at a
distance and that layer separation is
deeply felt at least to me i don't think
we need to stop teaching to kill a
mockingbird but i think it should be
followed up with a building's roman that
actually puts you in the space of a
black person
rather than a white child and also
please stop naming your children after
fictional characters it's very hard for
every khaleesi out there right now at
least wait until the series is over
take that jesus no i'm sorry jesus it's
fine i love you my bad